president biden with the pope a deeply
personal and spiritual moment for the
us's second ever catholic president but
also a chance to discuss the most
pressing issues at the top of the list
the climate emergency the biden
administration had hoped by now to have
passed its massive spending legislation
giving the president the ability to
match his words on climate with action
but there's been no breakthrough
as the u.s president toured rome with
his motorcade of 85 vehicles the un
secretary general said all roads to
success at the climate conference in
glasgow in just a few days pass through
rome
what is the minimum g20 countries must
deliver at this summit for there to be a
chance of a success at cop 26 in glasgow
we are still
above
what the scientists tell us that are
the levels of
emission that
should be needed in 2030 and in 2050
and
it is clear that it leads nowhere
if developed countries will try to blame
emerging economies and emerging
economies will try to blame developed
countries
this is the moment for everybody to do
the maximum
g20 leaders have been arriving in the
italian capital including some like the
australian prime minister scott morrison
and the brazilian president j bolsonaro
who faced the most criticism from
climate campaigners
a senior u n source has told me that the
pre-summit negotiations conducted by the
leaders envoys known as sherpas have
been extremely difficult there's been
some positive movement on the global
distribution of covert 19 vaccinations
but on the key issue the climate
emergency has been absolutely no
progress
another issue complicating things is the
fact that some leaders notably russia's
president putin and china's president xi
will not be traveling to rome or glasgow
and will be attending this g20 remotely
james bay's al jazeera rome